you
hi everyone is Jerry I'm on chest I come
and I am also on take number three I had
an issue with my recording software
twice alrights the wing gambit that's a
first
how do we approach this
I think the move here is d5 um although
you know another approach is I think to
simply go be five let's just put a pond
in the center yeah and how about maybe
and develop and hold off on capturing
that pond
you might be a little poison maybe I can
take him on my next move I'm just opting
for some rapid development
I could take here
any issue with
let's find out
all righty
I thought you might do that
though let's put another pawn in the
center my knight will be pushed back and
this pawn will be one however do I not
have this check that could be
interesting
let's give that a go yeah and here takes
Queen takes I have this and they're in a
pen they're not able to hunt down a
piece on c3 so it's already pretty messy
huh yeah they're taken out of their book
I guess okay and on this I could just
capture here first with the night now
let's do
Queen takes pawn
otherwise they're just gonna be up a
pond you know you have to go for that
and you probably also have to take this
pond here Bishop to e6 queen tase g7 hmm
I can move my knight with Czech boy this
is pretty messy all right I'm gonna try
to keep Queens on the board I think my
king will be safer they're gonna take on
g7 now so this should just be excellent
for me I'm not down any material
yeah just double-checking there and yeah
I guess we just take here the king is
now in the open
castles 97 and everybody's happy
yeah
home 97 incoming where the forceful
moves let's start with this Queen a5
check
she gonna go here clean here striking at
the rook yes it's identified checks
let's identify unprotected pieces rook
unprotected a check here and yeah let's
just rattle off a quick move here
pressure on f4 pressure on the rook and
how about a rook here and then we have
Queen c3 as an idea I have coordination
here they could try to challenge this
configuration and I guess we're gonna
have a quick W here that's a free rook
the wing gambit they're playing on
they're playing on
um
Klingon they had
thoughts on this one okay well that's
one of the quicker games hmm okay what
to add with this one that's a 15 mover
the Wing gambit I think of the majority
of the games I've played I don't think
I've really ever played this on the
white end this gambit but
yeah
the normal approach that I take here is
playing d5 but that could kind of get
chased around you know your opponent
grab some Tempe against your queen you
know I always feel like I need to know I
feel like I'm going into a territory
that my opponent is uh better prepared
for so another approach is the one that
I took in the game to just not even go
pawn hunting yeah you take once but
after a three you just get on with very
classical approach put upon in the
center emphasis on development let's
sort of just dive right into the
analysis here let me just bring it up
okay this is where I want to be so as I
was saying wing gambit
d 5 you could go a t5 I'm almost certain
how bad can that really be he takes B
and yeah the emphasis here is on rapid
development at some stage maybe I do
scoop up this pun
saved him which is a bother to my queen
night but
I get the epon and it's a struggle for
them to get the material back this is
already better for black here what does
white have to do and reply to Knight f6
c3 that's a little bit awkward yeah not
only defending the pond I mean what do
they do
b5 was played getting out of Bishop
takes pawn but maybe it's important to
stop a Bishop b4 move all together
that's a really awkward move to play c3
another one was Knight to f3 I think it
popped up but now maybe yeah nice I'm
gonna jump right in there and capture on
d4 Knight takes e5 and okay let's castle
lead in development
very thing that white is trying to
acquire with the gambit you know give up
upon in search of rapid development but
uh kind of backfired here in just a
couple more moves Queen e2 d5
and yeah I guess this is just excellent
for me with the move Bishop b4
and of the line that I was highlighting
here
the time I spent thinking about before
was calculating this advance but I could
take oh and that's not even best it
suggests Queen c7 that's sharp
pawn takes Bishop Queen takes bishop
pawn takes Knight Bishop takes pawn and
then you're on the Brooke I won't have
played Queen c7 on c3 I would have
captured here and on check here I was
content with Queen e7 holding his equal
Queen take c7 King take c7 and aa kind
of Bishop to d2
yeah even if position
been a sharp reply here right on c3
Queen c7 not really the first move that
comes to mind but anyhow as this played
out Bishop b4 92 likes Bishop c3 any
issue with Knight takes Knight still
holding an advantage and I felt after I
blocked with my Bishop the Queen has to
maybe try to pick up the g7 pawn but I
guess I could just rescue my knight what
would happen on Queen takes g7 I play
Knight to e4 ah Knight to e4 and then no
matter where the King goes I get to save
my night with Czech jumping into c3 and
King D won at minimum it seems pretty
appealing as well but just to highlight
I could play Knight there
and save my rook at the very least and
I'm up I'm up a minor piece there's much
better but yeah worst case scenario
that's that's the way I'm rescuing my
piece if Queen takes pawn there and with
this Bishop takes and yeah I have a lead
in development and their king is on
Castle it's gonna be bad news so here
there is it already gone after Queen f6
yeah that's what I played and it is gone
plus two minus two yeah they just didn't
see that the wreck was hanging you know
just dropped a piece there Queen takes
and then they resigned after some
thought after playing Knight to f3 but
from here I mean do we even go any
further
rook a3 how am I to continue here I
don't know if I would have played Knight
to the suggested Knight to b6 what is
that what is that looking to do even
maybe Knight b6 with the push and then
Knight to d5 let me just carry it out a
couple more moves Knight b6 what's the
idea with this night to be six move o to
two just eventually challenge the Queen
rook ft8 offer of a queen exchange I
would decline I had the safer King
okay yeah cuz it feels a bit awkward to
do this because I don't know where his
next forward move is you know my pawns
got that covered and my getting to d5 by
playing here but I guess yeah just
challenging the Queen position and
trying to sneak over towards the Queen
side would be the idea
okay miniature game feel free to leave
any feedback to this one any fans of the
winged gamut any viewers play the winged
gamut feel free to leave any feedback to
this video in the comment section below
hope for having a great day and I will
catch you soon that's all for now
take care
you